what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a video that was sent
to me by one of my subscribers on
instagram um tate on girls that are
battled by cheating before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell while
you're at it i also just launched my
first sweatshirt line um i'm wearing it
now it's the jpt i love these
sweatshirts so if you support me and you
want to support the channel feel free to
you know
help a girl out you feel me like
but anyways also
send me stuff on instagram i need more
stuff to react to lately
this is loud getting more high tech with
my
intros as you can see
so today's topic is girls who are
baffled by cheating
every day i scroll through facebook i'm
looking for a particular post looking
for those [ __ ] bimbos who who's man
cheating on them instead of sitting
there like a good woman looking in the
mirror and saying my tits are a little
saggy and i don't listen enough oh of
course that's why he cheated instead
they want to go on facebook and go men
are the enemy oh my god why did he do it
i can't believe he did it i'm so
confused what are you confused about
[ __ ] when's the last time you cooked
him dinner
do you suck dick on demand yes or no do
you obey this dude's out there every day
[ __ ] working and he comes home to
hear [ __ ] from you
and then oh my gosh i do not like him oh
my gosh
i mean i understand what you you're he's
saying right i'm i'm a logical person so
i hear him he's saying like if you're a
bad girlfriend
clearly like your man's gonna cheat on
you but
cheating's a values thing guys like
you're either a cheater you're not a
cheater
you if you're in a bad relationship
leave it like the sudden excuse to go
cheat on your girlfriend
you are the only female on earth he's
allowed to have sex with and when he
wants sex you don't want it so he has to
go through his life sexlessly because
you're a [ __ ] frigid assho
and you're confused he cheated i don't
understand why i understand why cause
you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] look
after your man bearer maybe he won't
[ __ ] cheat in all cheating scenarios
100 of the blame is always on the female
oh my god it's true because if you
looked after your man properly let me
tell you something men are a lot more
lazy than you give us credit for we
can't be bothered to go out there
find some bimbo talk [ __ ] to her take
her for dinner buy her some [ __ ] listen
to her opinions on [ __ ] her favorite
dog breed and scroll oh yeah your
instagram filter yeah i'll take the
picture men we don't want to do none of
that we do it because eventually there's
some sex at the end if you gave him
enough sex at home he's not gonna bother
with that [ __ ] why am i gonna talk to
this [ __ ] my [ __ ] already sucks dick i
don't need to if your man's cheating
it's because you ain't looking after him
right so stop damn
i from
what i've seen just like personal
experience
you're either the type of guy that
cheats or you're not it's not going to
make a difference
if your girl
is hooking up with you or not i mean i
will say like outside of like sexless
marriages if you haven't had sex with
your husband in like three years
like at that point maybe you guys should
get a divorce
um
do i agree with i do agree with him that
most guys are too lazy to cheat
confusion stop being baffled i'm telling
you right now why he did it so you
stopped going on facebook with all these
other [ __ ] girls below i know i
can't believe it my man cheated too
cause you're all low quality pieces of
[ __ ] that's why the men are cheating
[ __ ] look after yourselves unless you
put some makeup on telling me beyonce
come on beyonce
come on
[ __ ] gut
sort yourself out so you can end that
confusion [ __ ]
while we're on subject is cheating if
your man does cheat the most stupid
thing you can do is leave him
you're going to leave the man you love
the man you were head over heels in love
with you're going to leave him yeah
who you don't love who's still gonna
cheat on you because you're still a
trash [ __ ] oh my god there's a point in
that at least keep the love going oh my
god
beyonce for i mean she didn't leave but
oh my gosh
i think he's talking to a specific type
of woman um
which is like
how i put it these like rowdy girls that
don't do anything for their husbands or
their boyfriends and just like are super
vulgar i know the type of girl he's
talking to
so i don't really take this stuff
personally
but some guys are just selfish honestly
like some guys it's always about them
and they're only thinking about
themselves and that's why they cheat
because they want to have sex with other
people
it's actually not
it's not like doesn't have anything to
do with you
like my gran oh my gosh this actually
reminds me of my grandma my grandma was
like
like such a good person you don't even
understand like she that woman was a
saint and she
had 13 kids
and
yeah my grandpa still cheated on her
and like she was loyal she like
yeah
anyways i was just thinking if i should
even say that on this live because i nah
i don't think my davis side of the
family watches my youtube channel that
closely
um
anyways guys don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time